o microtédio de um projeto biologia da
nossa escola criado por quatro anos e
andré dias o palace chapéu lopes e pedro
favor vocês não precisam de férias
janete se não joga mais votada hoje em
dia todos nós sabemos que a energia ea
energia temos uma visão eletrodomésticos
e um destes e muito provavelmente já
todos nós andamos cá mas nós enquanto
seres vivos utilizá los
o atp estarão totalmente no sangue e
está em todas as células do nosso corpo
é esta pequena molécula ainda aquilo que
nós deixaremos e hélton luiz é foi a
primeira falta de energia que nós
conseguíssemos mais crescemos pizza
servia para tudo mesmo
vamos ver como ajudar nos a pensar na
primeira intervenção externa de energia
é em meados do país torcendo por alguns
absurdos da menina
o homo erectus vistos encontraram pedras
de fogo
o fogo foi um elevado
foi mesmo uma maneira nova de ver o
mundo pela primeira vez nós conseguimos
ver em uma toalha noite e aumentar
exponencialmente o valor no sentido
daquilo que comemos
o que nos deixou desenvolver mais o
nosso cérebro tal forma que só
conseguimos levar o homem à lua em 1969
desenvolvemos pela primeira vez um curso
progressão biônica funcional em 2015
o instrumento da copa nome dos nossos os
nossos hábitos
a norma da ans na nossa ano passado
acabou por sentir a necessidade da jada
11 uma fonte de energia constante para
realizar essas e tantas outras
atividades do dia a dia
exatamente a nossa energia é nossa vida
sedentária entre você tá outros há em
energia mecânica com nós conseguimos
captar como vênus a força de serem mais
é coisa das águas etc
no intuito de unir a nossa qualidade
afirma mas quando é que lá disse nadal
a série começou o fogo a energia mas eu
não posso me furtar de galera
portanto eu preciso não é legal europa
com uma grande função até chegarmos aos
dias deus mas o principal marco de
energia foi invenção cultura foi por
escrito sater originals andrew em 200
antes de cristo é preciso um projeto
viável em 1712 vão colocar o crescimento
de 1 deu newcomer que foi posteriormente
melhorado por jeans botas funcionavam
essencialmente a mão e foram os
principais impulsionadores da função
social
os 300 usar o petróleo porque é muito
mais eficiente que o adversário tem a
sua origem no egito 150 anos antes de
cristo convencer o seu primeiro filho da
filha foi construída em 800 para o nome
é chamado o avançado volta a um homem
que depois temos o nome originário ano
do seminário de alto nível e nós estamos
à espera que me quer por volta desta
ilha ao contrário dos motores funcionava
com um funcionava graças à abstenção
mesmo químicos mas apenas entrou ao
eficiente e funcional com um modelo de
chan foi desenho em 1836 já pensando na
quantidade de energia que nós consumimos
diariamente
não se sabe muito sobre isso os carros
já foram retirados e só é cerca de 15
lotes ou seja quem espera justiça por
cima é descobrir ter um cisto para
termos uma noção para lâmpadas significa
que poderíamos ter é seja
simultaneamente 151 milhões de dólares
assim sendo a quantidade de energia
elétrica que nós construímos um só viana
este podia ter cerca de 86 mil e 400
euros resulta no número de josué de
energia totalmente impensável um
autêntico absurdo isso significa que nós
precisamos fazer algumas regras mais
eficaz e mais sustentáveis arranjaremos
de ano existe sensação entre três dias e
os discos no vagas e assim nos dias pt
assim nos dias não provar que não
provadas como o próprio nome indica sua
energia cuja taxa de consumo é muito
superior à sua taxa posição é a natureza
mas pior kiss é mesmo a utilização de
combustíveis fósseis cuja a emitir gases
são os principais responsáveis pelo
aumento da poluição ambiental do efeito
estufa e do aquecimento global e ii é
ter mesmo de chuvas assuntos
para além disso a extração petrolífera e
transporte de petróleo são não é
processo muito meticulosos que exigem
bastantes cuidados bicho crescimento em
qualquer um destes processo pode causar
com um gigantesco petróleo já que na
maioria dos casos acaba por afetar de
forma negativa é
temas marinhos internos as energias
verdes cirurgias que utilizam recursos
renováveis e que são tendencialmente
menos prejudiciais para o para o meio
ambiente
entre os destaques energia eólica eles
disso a energia hidroelétrica e
hidráulica e nos desviam técnica energia
mario triste é em energia nuclear e os
biocombustíveis
ok então nós conseguimos obter energia
abasteça os seus vivo dos seus livros
meus colegas desde animais plantas
trotes estas bactérias mas não tanto
estes últimos e apresentam um
grandíssimo potencial em relação com as
outras formas de vida existentes
inverter de todas as formas e feitios eu
estou todo a austrália go na nossa casa
no nosso corpo e nossa comida ea nossa
roupa e estima se que existam cinco
vezes desde novata 30 microorganismos
produzem e taxas impressionantes e um de
seus processos distintos de perto né
três livros podem ser reaproveitados
para a produção que venci lá então o
projeto micro energia nasceu de quatro
colegas e amigos e não projeto
obrigatória de deus dia
nós fizemos um trabalho sobre aldeias
mais especificamente decote blame fosse
assim não tinha qualquer parte prática
entre as facções sobre os efeitos de
medidas estejam em habitats naturais
renováveis agrícolas
nós estamos inicialmente mota engil é
infelizmente em todos os jogos -
morreram estéreo e coração só dos
aposentados
para evitar mais retornados acidente
mudará o rumo da nossa apresentação
desta vez tenho de tomar um espírito
mais empreendedora e queremos criar um
projeto que fosse totalmente abalada
esta bolsa de valores
o tributo teve uma idéia fantástica e se
assim for bem mas com obras
nós estávamos muito existentes nas aulas
no entanto ainda construindo os vários
planos caminhão com elas
só precisamos realmente as dimensões do
nosso problema com os vizinhos esta
imagem que é uma casa na alemanha
funciona é apenas a base de aulas porque
pode produzir quantidades aceitáveis de
energia são os sites de vários meios de
combate à inflação é que nós liga ea
teoria fala toda do nosso lado
agora é ter descoberto que o senhor
chamado receptor ter uma idéia é
exatamente um segundo antes de nós pode
não ser muito conhecido pelo seu
trabalho mas no entanto brincam é
posteriormente descobriu que são de gás
duas destas selvas inserem conseguiria
encontrar conseguiria fazer uma corrente
elétrica com uma diferença de potencial
de 135 moldes e como
o inverso é exatamente um sucesso
utilizada também a fermentação com um
crescimento orgânico
estas células e objetos que achamos
nairóbi o phil céus oh e mercês e nós no
nosso projeto é exatamente fazer uma
célula destino deu com base nesses
princípios teóricos mas apenas com
materiais do cotidiano
temos que saber que nós ainda não acabou
com nosso projeto porque ainda faltam os
testes finais mas o nosso produto como
podem ver aqui é constituído por dois
anos
no primeiro encontro encontra encontrar
se á uma e nutritivo e vários tipos de
bactérias prova da motivação dobra os
joelhos enquanto o segundo estava cheio
de água
além disso anos sonho um eléctrodo os
ligados entre si por esse fio de cobre
em cima e finalmente este comportamento
estão ligados por uma coisa que se chama
pontos no primeiro quarto quando está o
intuitivo é utilizá-lo como forma de
obter energia neste processo digestivo
resultam é então tá após o óxido são
negócios de óxido de carbono protões ou
seja 11 milhões positivos de hidrogênio
e um de três leis mas como este se
encontra isolado é esse através deste
programa vão reger a osesp segundo o
bonde se encontra a água com bastante
prestígio neste compartimento finalmente
vai acontecer a solução é inclusive
através dos próprios e oxigênio vão
juntar formando água oxigênio
chamamos nessa reta final do relatório
mas que foram inclusive entre os protões
passam de um compartimento do primeiro
compartimento o nosso mundo é bastante
simples
os deputados por este meio copo até ao
fim compartimento china e no transporte
importante é o índice é muito importante
que exijam concentração adequada de
proteínas um compartimento para que
exista um fluxo contínuo e consideravam
eletrônico só são utilizados este fluxo
é temos lucas elétrica que pode ser
usada diversos fins
a cantar todos nós sabemos que a
poluição ambiental é muito prejudicial
para a saúde sendo que muitos dos seus
efeitos não são muito mais conhecidos
pelo público em geral
arranca association for santos - saias
jeans em 2016 cerca de 5.5 milhões de
pessoas morrem todos os gastos do
governo
mas apesar da gravidade dessa
instituição porque nosso fazenda porque
existem vermos empresas que impedem o
progresso científico que no fundo acaba
por ser a força motriz da proteção
ambiental
diferentemente de seus tacos nós somos
jovens vão construir o futuro temos a
obrigação de fazer com que as lanchas
nossos convidados
temos de ser reticentes mexem ativos na
sociedade quando nós estamos no mundo à
nossa volta temos provado ser críticos
justiça e autonomistas também temos de
estar munidos de ser incomparáveis e
totalmente ano em vídeos documentos
realizados e temos ainda que saber dar
os passos certos não e com bateria não
ficamos apenas 509 seguinte fazer algo
por esta situação seriam já uma maneira
de sustentar vão criar energia sendo que
assim não iriam gostar até por ele e
destruir nosso planeta
a nossa ideia finalizou numa ação
microbial que apesar do seu
funcionamento é bastante simples pudesse
talvez utah origem já tive mais
avançados mais sólido e com mais
investimento a nós ganharmos estes
projectos e ultrapassarmos as
dificuldades e não só estados e
presentes deve dizer que cumprimos o
nosso objetivo
ao compreender os objetivos acabamos por
concluir que não faz sentido ter medo
está parado
não ter medo de agir andar falar e
pensar criar em dez dias pôr em prática
não vejo sinto que é preciso ações
faltam livros da apresentação anterior
é meu infelizmente da distância a que
este estágio nós nós queremos mesmo esse
ano se vir um dia talvez nós conseguimos
nosso conjunto talvez não consigamos
entender que lula talvez não saiba mas
friends que 150 iuans lâmpadas só pelo
dia dela
esse é o nosso projeto e chegamos na
crônica muito obrigado